seit es sie gibt wird die sommerzeit
diskutiert denn ihr nutzen ist sagen wir
mal eben diskutable tatsächlich ist
vollkommen umstritten ob sie die
prognostizierten energieeinsparungen
bringt denn wissenschaftlich steht
dieser nutzen mehr als in frage
ist das also alles quatsch und wird sie
deshalb bald abgeschafft wir beantworten
alle fragen rund um die sommerzeit jetzt
mal klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
die geschichte der sommerzeit ist sagen
wir mal eine geschichte voller
missverständnisse
ein bisschen erinnert sie an den blau
milch kanal eine erfundene geschichte um
einen kanal quer durch die israelische
stadt der lavive den gebaut wurde weil
irgendein verrückter damit anfing ein
loch zu buddeln
und ein bisschen ist es wohl auch so bei
der sommerzeit denn eigentlich gibt es
überhaupt keinen grund für sie aber der
reihe nach das erste mal wurde die
sommerzeit von deutschland und
österreich-ungarn während des ersten
weltkriegs eingeführt weil man sich da
durch energieeinsparungen versprach mit
der eingesparten energie
damals wurden städte noch mit gas
beleuchtet strom wurde mit kohle
hergestellt wollte man diese rohstoffe
für das militär einsparen doch dass man
durch das ausnutzen der hellen
morgenstunden mehr energie einspart ist
mehr als umstritten im gegenteil alle
bekannten untersuchungen kommen zu dem
ergebnis dass der minderverbrauch zu
vernachlässigen ist das ergebnis war
meistens das zwar weniger künstliche
beleuchtung benötigt wird aber mehr
geheizt wird 2005 fasste die
bundesregierung diese erkenntnisse noch
mal in einer antwort auf eine kleine
anfrage der fdp fraktion zusammen und
heute dürften die auswirkungen sogar
umgekehrt seien dadurch dass die
beleuchtung deutlich weniger energie
verbraucht als noch vor zehn jahren
dürfte der effekt inzwischen umgekehrt
sein
wir dürfen also durch das verstärkte
heizen mehr energie verbrauchen aber
darüber gibt es keinerlei erkenntnisse
ohmann es ist schon ein wenig bescheuert
ein insektenforscher der keine ahnung
von energieverbräuchen energiebilanzen
undsoweiter hatte trug diese idee
erstmals 895 vor george birnen hudson
präsentierte seine vermeintlichen
erkenntnisse der royal society of new
zealand und irgendwie hielt sich dann
diese irrglaube doch die
energieeinsparung so heute gar nicht
mehr der grund für die einführung der
sommerzeit der eigenen
grund ist die harmonisierung derzeit in
europa um den handel zu erleichtern
so steht das explizit in der
stellungnahme der bundesregierung moment
moment moment also wie bitte noch mal
ganz langsam die sommerzeit gibt es weil
sie andere mal eingeführt haben
vollkommen rund und wir uns jetzt in
europa nach diesen ländern richten
obwohl es gar keinen sinn macht und
heute wahrscheinlich sogar zu höheren
energie verbrauchen führt das ist
wirklich wahnsinn das ist echt ein
schildbürgerstreich
das ist ja so als würden wir gar kein
vergleich an das ist echt so verrückt
wie bei per anhalter durch die galaxis
live ist stranger than fiction kann man
wirklich sagen wir sollten wir den welt
handtuch tag gesetzlich einführen und
dabei sind die gesundheitlichen folgen
noch nicht berücksichtigt viele menschen
beklagen schlafstörungen schlappheit und
eine schwedische studie kommt sogar zu
dem ergebnis dass in den tagen nach der
zeitumstellung mehr menschen einen
herzinfarkt erleiden und umfragen kommen
auch zu dem ergebnis dass die
zeitumstellung von der mehrheit der
bevölkerung abgelehnt wird so rund 70
prozent sind meistens dagegen doch
niemand will sie abschaffen allerdings
hat das eu parlament jetzt die eu
kommission also die regierung von europa
beauftragt den nutzen zu überprüfen und
die sommerzeit gegebenenfalls
abzuschaffen es könnte also vielleicht
doch weil es spannend werden mich würde
aber mal jetzt interessieren was ihr
jetzt nachdem er die hintergründe kennt
von der zeitumstellung haltet ich starte
gleichauf whatsapp eine umfrage dort und
nur dort werdet ihr auch das ergebnis
erfahren wenn er also mitmachen wollt
dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei
whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über
mich in der redaktion von krieg so
mitmachen und mit themen vorschlagen
oder eben an abstimmungen teilnehmen und
mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum so
passiert der direkte draht zu mir
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich
nicht das abo mit der genau glocke
vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
dafür auch draufklicken die genaueste
uhr der welt ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran